niché dans les montagnes qui soit comme
porto spain part à miner le pays décide
du fameux oignons pays comme le clame en
créole ce chansonnier de 75 ans la
localité est réputé à trinidad pour ses
épices cultivés à flanc de colline la
vidéo
pam entre nous pourquoi parlez vous
comprends amendo conjoint ou les
roannais qui montrent la buissière n'y
allez pas beau la guadeloupe à la
pression sinon on va ramener ces civils
jeannot jouit comme on le surnomme
maîtrise parfaitement la richesse et la
saveur du patois trinidadien créole très
proche de celui des antilles françaises
son village de parent ami n'est
considérée comme le fief des derniers
créolophones toute une génération sa
génération parle encore la langue parlée
qui se remarque aussi dans le paysage
mois ci n'est pas le papa oui des fois
qu'on sent que les canaux tnt parole à
anglet
si on est perdu par là mais paula et
rappelle toi qu'on s'approchait du mal à
key west et lil pu couper une ost et
pirro à poils ont l'âge moins tranchant
çà et là les apparats mille le créole
s'est transmis pendant des années
naturellement de génération en
génération
c'est le cas chez les félix une famille
dont le patriarche est encore vivant
l'âge au plat joué dans qui nous freine
nos failles vous faites vous venez à
gaza s'est écrasée comme l année sa
jeune élève ce grand centenaire fait la
fierté de ses 14 enfants d'une bonne
centaine de petits enfants et de tout le
village
francis félix est le doyen de trinidad
et tobago cela lui a d'ailleurs valu
l'an dernier la visite du président de
la république trinidadienne avec il a
dialogué en créole évidemment car dans
la famille félix on parle la langue sans
complexe à présent on pourrait quitter
le pouvoir
et puis nos blessés mais un roi soins
qui doit pas nous vous avons dit monique
wittig venture dans les pattes d'oie
point le battoir vous même comme ces
tunis ap en bas de page de panique les
surprendre ou à lille ou paris ou pas sa
connaissance pas jouer et qu'on a tous
envie ne lui ouvre pas savoir les sas a
hissé le bypass havre latine asie panne
sur cette terre bien exposé de par amine
génie et son mari bichonnent leurs mis
pied tomates
cette agricultrice de 62 ans dans les
origines sont en partie vénézuélienne a
aussi été bercée par le créole un
héritage quelles attentes et transmettre
à ses enfants
mais comme les tomates la nouvelle
génération a tendance à rougir de cette
langue
yo pa et mais l'oeil au sorteo pavlé
parler patois et on voulait pas les
anglais et paillotes corses
par contre oui oui oui et on vante with
wes a dit ça c'est beau c'est au parc à
paris ceux qui parlent encore couramment
créoles ont plus de 50 ans dans le
modeste bourdeu par amine on peut encore
entendre çà et là des échanges notamment
aux abords des commerces de proximité
même si le créole anglais prédomine
pourtant par amina brille encore des
événements étroitement liée à la langue
mon cas
le créole est présente dans les rituels
comme les veillées où la liturgie chaque
année mais c'est même entièrement
célébré en patois
donc oui j'ai dit ma joie un carnaval
oui il ya tout là mais ça c'est pas toi
j'ai parfois des massa au chômage
les bombes de la chorale paroissiale
maîtrise parfaitement le répertoire des
chants créoles
mais ces jeunes femmes reconnaissent ne
pas parler la langue même si elle la
comprennent assez bien et l'apprécient
quand vous chantez en créole ça vient du
coeur pour vous sentez différence n'est
pas comme chantait en anglais vous
ressentez quelque chose de plus profond
vous vous sentez beaucoup plus en
contact avec dieu
l'impression que le seigneur est plus
près de vous
nos parents ne voulaient pas que nous
apprenions le créole il pensait que
c'était une sorte de langue du passé
pour la nouvelle génération dit
maintenant nous en voyons la nécessité
c'était une bonne langue il faut la
maintenir en vie c'est une bonne culture
c'est essentiel pour notre village le
village de par amine donc nous essayons
de la faire vivre et maintenant mon papa
me parle beaucoup plus en créole
il n'a plus honte parce que c'était le
langage de la honte auparavant tout en
haut de par amine sur le versant donnant
sur la mer caraïbe
ce rasta de 63 ans cultive son créole
comme l'oignon pays qu'il continue de
planter
bien souvent les deux vont de pair et il
n'en a pas honte
même si les créolophones ont souvent été
montrées du doigt la vie dans cette zone
rurale quasi isolé a permis de préserver
le patois de l'anglicisation de cadix à
semoun qui sortit indications qui cap à
l'est ces qualités là naissent
myopathies quotas pour thann ou capa
l'egypte m si nous l idaho poids est
éloquent pas les patois ou qui jouent en
cavale et nous forcer chisinau des
carottages des cas si oui rassoul you
l'eiu les palais pour nous pas qu'on
prenne pas part à part toi d'y caser me
nettoie dit oh quitter sa part les
anglais
c'est ok t'es plus parler on les bat et
nouveau léopard les nouveaux panneaux
qui parlait patois le bar du village
demeure l'un des derniers lieux
d'expression en tout cas pour les
anciens ici les habitués se rencontrent
sirotant un verre et s'exprime sans
complexe dans cette langue
longtemps stigmatisés
jeudi nous langage ça va nous en parlent
ce langage cochon et puis double par
l'esa et puis yoyo faite une bagarre et
après ça se passe ainsi qu'à parler
patois local du café ou du cas d'eric
aussi aux ou s'ils recourent à la hoya
au kosovo c'est bête et puis offert sa
meilleure amie de sale année après année
mais séoul a joué le créole n'a pas
toujours eu cette place dans la société
trinidadienne bien au contraire
pour nous en convaincre ce professeur
docteur en linguistique spécialiste
notamment des aspects socio historique
nous entraîne à la bibliothèque de
l'université des west indies le créole
fait partie de son héritage familial
elle tient à nous montrer un ouvrage de
référence en matière d'étude du créole
c'est le premier ouvrage au monde
le g après elle et c'était écrit par
john jacob toros en 1869
cette toute première grammaire écrite il
ya près de 150 ans devait faciliter
l'intégration des nouveaux immigrants
qui débarquait à trinidad indien arabe
chinois tout ça prenait le créole au
xviiie siècle c'était la langue
d'unification de l'île tout entière
trinidad n'a jamais été occupée par la
france mais beaucoup de colons des
antilles françaises se sont installés
avec leurs esclaves du temps où il était
espagnole tout le monde tout le monde
parlait un créole à cette époque là
donc s'il y avait seulement 8000
espagnol il y avait 20 20 mille
l'euphonie francophones qui sont venus à
swindon
donc ce sont les français qui ont
vraiment colonisé colonisé colonisé
trainer socialement culturellement
encore que la plupart de notre coeur les
d'origine martiniquaise sa venue à
travers la grenade
c'était la langue nationale la langue
locale c'était beaucoup plus important
le français ou l'anglais à une certaine
époque mais en 1804 quelque chose comme
40 quelque chose il ya eu un processus
et un une politique d'organisation qui a
beaucoup affecté le créole et les
locuteurs du créole c'est est visé aux
français parce que c'était une petite
guerre entre les onglets anglophones et
les français franck francophones et
créolophones
les rochers nous chers
les tout premiers califes souhaitait
chanter en créole preuve de la vivacité
de la langue reste est dominante
jusqu'aux années 1930
l'usagé de l'anglais a pris le dessus
mais se parler créole a laissé une forte
empreinte sur la langue utilisée
quotidiennement par les trinidadiens on
en trouve encore des traces dans le
parler tous les jours parce qu'ici faut
savoir catherine sadon par l'ancien
autres créole à base lexicale anglaise
qu'on appelle dialect ici et qui
contient beaucoup beaucoup de mots
qu'ils éduquent roll français
et plein d'exemples c'est un peu
triviale bamako par exemple c'est un
beau qu'on entend tous les jours et
qu'on retrouve par exemple en guadeloupe
et en martinique
donc il ya beaucoup de maux de la vie
quotidienne qui sont restés dans lequel
anglophone ici au quotidien il y a
beaucoup de mots sur le nature nos
fruits et légumes noaves notre carnaval
les fruits comme pomme de terre où tous
les membres il y a mango vers mango
douces mangues aux empilements go qui
avec qui ont des noms et la syntaxe
créole et il ya des autres qui ont des
noms plutôt anglais comme giuly manou
pour ça
au match aller à metz
c'est pour ça et moi pas tu es capoue
n'diaye c'est pour ça est mort et tous
les samedis ce professeur de langues
anime un atelier d'initiation au créole
à calpe aaron communauté rurale située
au coeur de trinidad ses élèves des
jeunes de 7 à 77 ans après marion de
façon ludique notamment par les chansons
ça
et
où et comment you et méchante et à yoyo
qu apprendre l'anglais facilement et
dérivant pas aisé séparé nous ça qu'ils
ont tous à coeur l'esprit nous même si
nous jouons
les
ouais sortie
mais où est il
et comme dit au joker partager sa
connaissance du créole il s'est pris de
passion pour cette langue qu'il a
apprise à l'université il a déjà produit
un recueil un cd de chansons
traditionnelles en patois c'est
aujourd'hui l'un des meilleurs
spécialistes et avocats du créole à
trinidad il a aussi développé sa propre
méthode d'enseignement et des
associations font régulièrement appel à
lui pour dispenser des cours de créole
smile le cap à l'est il faut en tout cas
tout bizarre pourtant avec a servi une
technologie à des placements
c'est un seuil ont chanté ont joué au
barça bis image associant les corps aux
mots ouverts à ce qu'on craque au
pouvoir à poil mots le ouvrir imagera
maccaferri quoi ça ne pouvait imager là
où pour connaître ça qui manque à la
lépi et sa prestance et belloumi
si les cours de nandy suscite l'intérêt
de l'assistance
c'est dans cette zone des plaines de
caroni au pouce est là calme quasiment
tout le monde un membre de sa famille
qui s'expriment où s'exprimaient en
patois comme on dise à grand-mère
connaissez le creal mon oncle aussi mais
ils ne nous ont pas transmis
je voudrais la prendre pour l'enseigné à
mes enfants
le coach en septembre où ils devaient
oui épi mais après le mans
sa mort évite une passe et une personne
allez-vous du oui encore quant au
montana oblige tout ici patates ou veufs
mon parti et puis pas thouars mon
premier contact avec le créole c'était
avec mon père donc pour moi c'est
sentimental je ressens que c'est mon
héritage paternel c'est notre culture
notre histoire qui est aussi comme je
suis enseignante je réalise que nos
enfants ne sont pas informés de ce qui a
été notre richesse culturelle ils ne
savent pas qu'à une certaine époque et
nous parlions le français et le créole
pas l'anglais donc c'est aussi une
passion le propager partout à trinidad
et tobago relancer le crédit
candidat au sourire
oui
retour à par amine dans ce bastion du
patois
nos deux spécialistes du créole nomme
10h et johan ferreira ratissent depuis
plusieurs années tout le territoire pour
collecter des témoignages enregistrés
les créolophones ils ont rendez vous ce
jour là avec trois anciens du village
un travail de mémoire est essentielle
afin de documenter cette langue
patrimoniale les matériels pourquoi pas
tout pour chercher comment c'est fait
beaucoup moins et après sa musique a
fait payer tous ces médias et là cela me
plaît mais vaut normalement quand on
vient apparemment histoire personnelle
et du village et les histoires les
contes traditionnels mais cette fois ci
on ne nous faut cueillir vocabulaire
pour des thèmes spécifiques pour des
cours on dit qu'on veut faire ensemble
donc l'anglais est en train de les citer
les données sur les couleurs
où les membres d'une famille dont lé
thème très spécifiques
non non non non méchoui du quad et si
oui si leurs femmes pilotes nomme les
ramasseurs cancellara c'est qu'en soit à
sept îles autonomes
on assistait au matin les c'est beau
l'amour c'est le toit de l'année ok mais
ni la bbc paca pas les échoppes opt in
show met au monde des minimoys dis ça
mais qu'elle essayait fait c'est pour
qu'il en restait en piste est séchante
et elle a une idée claire c'est pour
vivre là on va considérer l'os est
content pour eelv et qu'il engage à rien
copaci camors sa sé moun an qui
commençait un clé si nous et puis palais
ça vous calcule pas le courage patois
mais un monde récit plein mon parti car
officia comme ont pâti kbc lambie comme
à sévigné cite à présent plus ou moins
et puis commencer mes nerfs différents
différents mots différents pays
et puis nous commencer observés çà nous
car j'étais salon cap et 10 imiter un
arrêt à -6 jeunesse la carabine à
présent l'est autant de noms quand pas
de quoi s'affoler parakou paris au parc
ont écrit aux familles a pour sa part sa
part les toboggans sa patronne et épicé
anglais au cap à l'est quand ça les
gênait la pause à leighton camp nou ka
palé la présence du cabba et nous pour
ces deux militants du créole la priorité
c'est d'archivés le plus possible de
contenus en créole afin que la langue ne
disparaissent sans laisser de traces
une partie de leurs entretiens sont sous
titrés en anglais est mis en ligne sur
le web un moyen de promouvoir et
revitalisé cet héritage linguistique sur
youtube même dix partagent les vidéos
qui ont valeur pédagogique et
patrimoniale mais c'est pour mon général
ouais prises avec un ep 1 min 27
décembre vidéo charline osaka qui unit
est un homme il visite une date de sa
visite m par exemple au monde qui tenir
une once de l'année et on the web ninjas
rsa et qui sont jeunes et donc c'est pas
nous c'est la nounou qui mérite et c'est
aussi important que ces listings a été
dramatique est important qu montponnais
tsariste x et inhibe allait jusqu'en
saioni dans leur pays at on même 17
initié au créole ici sur ce campus
universitaire de saint augustine la
faculté des sciences humaines dispense
des cours de créole depuis 1991
elle une matière facultative pour
beaucoup d'étudiants
du coup ils ne sont chaque année qu'une
poignée pour cette rentrée universitaire
d'où seulement suivent les cours de ce
professeur de créole originaire de
sainte lucie à s'allier à un coup ça la
peau si cela n'est cette l'année
écoulée l'année mois coincée étudiants
apprenez vite à ses côtés trois mois six
mois
yoyo caf poignée assez bien ma vraie ap
ap un homme
beaucoup y aller avec l'offre si des
gens ici à l'université qui pensent que
le créole et le une perte totale ils
pensent que
me la région caribéenne à seulement
quatre langues anglais français espagnol
et à l'année mais ils connaissent même
pas que la première langue espagnole est
la deuxième langue le créole c'est aussi
l'espagnol à welt appelle deux millions
de personnes le créole tout seul à plus
de 9 9 millions et anglais vin vient
l'horaire avec 6 millions le créole ni
par ici aussi bien aura signé que si
majestueux zaman à 6 ans brad lui qui
trône au milieu du campus de st
augustine on ne sait pas précisément
combien de personnes parlent encore le
bateau à trinidad
mais il est en danger tous les experts
prédisent sa disparition depuis près de
40 ans dans la conscience nationale
c'est ça que d'amener mois on essaie de
faire ensemble
mais des deux camps langue une langue
n'est pas paraît pas un enfant comme
langue maternelle
ça c'est le signe de la disparition
donc le plus jeune qu'on connaît
il a déjà 40 mais quand on a fait sa
connaissance il avait 30 en deux et pour
nous ça c'était une grande surprise
connaître quelqu'un qui était déjà assez
jeune mais il n'y a pas selon ce qu'on a
découvert il n'y a pas d'enfant qui le
par comme langue maternelle
et ça c'est le problème du mama do do
pinces et si papa de petit garçon
prénommé croit mythe même dit aux rêves
de transmettre le créole à sa
descendance
il a commencé à verser son fils de
refrains en patois avec la douce
espérance je veux préparer la prochaine
génération de créolophones trinidad